I am the presiding officer of the
national assembly for wales and one of
my key roles is to ensure that all the
people of Wales are able to engage with
this Emily's work whether through the
Welsh or the English language and that's
why we've been working with Microsoft to
create a machine translation tool to
help the assembly to meet our own
language goals it will also put the
Welsh language on the world stage by
providing a translation tool that is
available to any Microsoft Customer
across the globe the Oakland very young
ebo or Microsoft a very big thank you to
everyone at Microsoft for helping us
develop this exciting new tool the
armbar